"9/11 AMNESIA" DESCRIBING IT
SELF, CLEARLY.
9/11 PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE IN
THE LIVES OF SO MANY AMERICANS,
CERTAINLY IN THE LIFE OF
CONGRESSWOMAN TULSI GABBARD OF
HAWAII, JOINING THE MILITARY
AFTER IT A TACK AND SERVED A
TOUR IN IRAQ, NOW SHE'S RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT.
CONGRESSMAN GABBARD JOINS TO US
TALK ABOUT 9/11.
THANKS A LOT FOR COMING ON
CONGRESSWOMAN.
>> THANK YOU.
.
>> Tucker: LOOKING BACK YOU HAVE
HAD TIME TO THINK ABOUT THIS IN
THE COUNTRY AND ABROAD.
WHAT ARE THE LESSONS FOR THE
REST OF US WOULD YOU SAY 18
YEARS LATER?
>> IT'S LOOKING BACK ON THAT
DAY, REMEMBERING WHERE WE WERE,
AND AS WE OBSERVED AL QAEDA
ATTACKING US, SEEING THOUSANDS
OF FELLOW AMERICANS KILLED ON
THAT DAY, AND SEEING THE BRAVE
ACTS THAT THESE HEROS, FIRST
RESPONDERS, PUT FORWARD AS THEY
RAN INTO THOSE CRUMBLING
BUILDINGS AS PEOPLE TRIED GET
OUT TO SEE HOW MANY PEOPLE THEY
COULD SAVE.
LIKE SO MANY AMERICANS, IT WAS
THIS EVENT THAT MADE ME DECIDE
IN MY OWN LIFE I WANTED TO
DEDICATE MY LIFE TO KEEPING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SAFE, TOO.
FINDING AND DEFEATING THOSE WHO
ATTACKED US ON THAT DAY, AND
PROTECTING OUR FREEDOMS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT CONTINUED
TO INSPIRE ME TODAY.
BUT ALSO, WE'VE GOT TO RECOGNIZE
HOW MUCH OUR LEADERS HAVE FAILED
US.
WHERE INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ONE
POINTEDLY ON DEFEATING AL QAEDA
AND AFFILIATES AND OFFSHOOTS,
INSTEAD THEY WENT AND STARTED
WAGING A SERIES OF REGIME CHANGE
WARS IN PLACES LIKE IRAQ AND
LIBYA AND THE ONGOING REGIME
CHANGE WAR IN SYRIA.
NOW, THIS HAS COST OUR COUNTRY
TRILLIONS OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
WE HAVE LOST THOUSANDS OF
AMERICAN LIVES IN THESE WARS
MIECHLT BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN
UNIFORM.
TO SPEAK OF THE COUNTLESS LIVES
LOST IN OTHER COUNTRIES IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
WHERE DO WE FIND OURSELVES
TODAY?
AL QAEDA IS STRONGER NOW THAN
THEY WERE ON 9/11.
THIS IS THE RESULT THAT WE HAVE.
>> Tucker: SO, I HAVE TO SAY,
I'M COMPLETELY CONVINCED THAT IF
YOU WOULD LEAVE THE LINE ABOUT
SYRIA OUT, IF YOU PRESENT TEND
THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING IN SYRIA
AND HAVE DONE IN SYRIA IS WISE
AND SMART, THAT YOU WOULD BE ON
THE STAGE WITH YOUR FELLOW
DEMOCRATS AT THE DEBATE.
BRINGING THAT YOU POINT ABOUT
SYRIA HAS EARNED YOU THE EVEN
MITT OF A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON, A LOT.
THE ENTIRE FOREIGN POLICY
ESTABLISHMENT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT IS SO
INTERESTING, TUCKER, IF YOU LOOK
BACK AROUND THE VOTE FOR THE
IRAQ WAR, YOU KNOW, THERE WERE
SOME FOLKS, VERY FEW FOLKS WHO
VOTED AGAINST THAT IRAQ WAR.
AND THEY WERE SMEARED, THEY WERE
ACCUSED OF HATING AMERICA, THEY
WERE CALLED UNPATRIOTIC.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN, NOW, WE ARE
WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
IT'S BECOME VOGUE FOR
POLITICIANS TO SAY HOW TERRIBLE
THAT IRAQ WAR WAS.
YET THEY LACK THE COURAGE TO
STAND UP AND SPEAK THE TRUTH
TODAY AGAINST THE ONGOING REGIME
CHANGE WAR IN SYRIA.
THAT'S NOT LEADERSHIP.
>> Tucker: NO, IT'S CERTAINLY
NOT.
SO, HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT BEING
EXCLUDED FROM THIS NEXT DEBATE?
>> THE DNC IS TRYING TO
BASICALLY SEND A MESSAGE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE
THE ALL POWERFUL GATE KEEPERS
AND THEY'RE THE ONES WHO HAVE
THE POWER TO DECIDE WHO SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED TO BE OUR
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE OR NOT.
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT VOTERS
IN THIS COUNTRY HAVE THAT POWER.
THAT'S WHERE I'M FOCUSED, I'M
FOCUSED ON REACHING OUT THE AND
CONNECTING WITH VOTERS.
THEY'RE THE ONES I'M COMMITTED
TO SERVING.
>> Tucker: YOU THINK THAT A
PARTY THAT BELIEVES IN DIVERSITY
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE MAYBE A
DIFFERENT POINT OF VIEW ON THE
ISSUE.
YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT POINT OF
VIEW SOME OF THE ISSUES.
>> I THINK THAT'S PART OF THE
PROBLEM, WITH THESE DEBATES, IS
WITH THESE 30-SECOND ANSWERS,
60-SECOND ANSWERS, YOU AREN'T
REALLY GIVING VOTERS THE CHANCE
TO HEAR WHERE DO WE STAND ON
THESE ISSUES, WHAT MOTIVATES US
WHY ARE WE DOING WHAT WE'RE
DOING, WHAT EXPERIENCE AND
CREDIBILITY DO WE WRING TO THE
JOB OF PRESIDENT AND THE HUGE
RESPONSIBILITY AS SERVING AS
COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
REALLY ALL IT BECOMES IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE HOSTING
MEDIA NETWORK TO GET HIGH
RATINGS OR MAKE SOME MONEY OFF
OF IT.
THE WHOLE THING IS A CHARADE.